all right guys bang-bang i've got
michael here with us thanks so much for
doing this man yeah great to chat I
think it's it's been too long since the
last time we sat down you have been hard
at work it appears like so for those
that haven't been paying attention
grayscale I think might have already
been the largest digital asset asset
manager but has continued to lengthen
that lead if you will and now the latest
numbers are four billion dollars in
assets first congratulations on that
thank you thank you
and maybe I figured let's just start
there I think that's like kind of a
headline number people see you know four
billion dollars in assets about two
billion of that it sounds like came over
the last twelve months
so maybe just walk us through from you
know your see running this absolute
beast of a company where's the money
coming from and what's driving those
investors to to seek out digital assets
and the structure that you guys have for
sure so first I just you know kind of
introduce grayscale for folks that that
don't know us
we are the world's largest digital
currency asset manager really for us
it's been about providing access and
exposure to the asset class and so today
we offer ten different investment
products where investors can gain
exposure to either a single digital
currency on in the case of some of our
single asset products or a basket of
digital currencies in the case of our
diversified fund grayscale Digital large
cap fund and I really think for
grayscale it's really been about not
trying to reinvent the wheel we've been
taking our cues from the incumbent asset
managers really trying to find the best
service providers we can and again the
way that investors are used to getting
exposure to either certain commodities
or certain subsets of the market they
can actually use greyscale to gain
exposure to different digital currencies
and I'd say you know for for most
investors you know greyscale has been
around now since late 2013 and while
it's been fantastic and rewarding to see
it become orders of magnitude easier for
investors to access to
currency directly many investors still
don't want to they don't want to figure
out where to buy digital currency how to
transfer it store it safe keep it and
the greyscale family a product really is
that all-in-one solution that looks
feels and acts the same way investors
have an experience buying you know any
other financial product that gives them
exposure to a commodity or again a
subset of the market for us today I'd
say overwhelmingly our inflows on into
the products where we actually are
directly raising assets is probably over
80% these days coming from the
institutional investors so I'd say we're
talking primarily about hedge funds non
crypto hedge funds but that also means
that we serve a whole swatch of high net
worth individuals family offices other
types of institutions financial advisors
our IAS and then because some of the
grayscale products are also publicly
quoted we also serve really any investor
that has access to the public markets
where they can trade in grayscale
products in their brokerage accounts IRA
accounts etc so I think that one of the
things I've seen a bunch of people kind
of arguing back and forth on Twitter
which always cracks me up I'm like hey
look I'll just ask the guy when I have
home ha our podcast is so idea of like
80 percent comes from institutions right
first of all that's an incredibly
impressive number I think it serves as a
great data point in terms of the
interest that's coming from those types
of organizations everything kind of the
detraction argument that I see on
Twitter is like Oh which ones aren't
institutions now I think you and I both
know that hedge funds by definition or
institutions I think it's more of this
thing where people kind of they're
talking about the endowments the
pensions the foundations the Wall Street
banks whatever when they say
institutions so maybe just help talk
through like one honey you guys think of
institutions and then also - if you can
just break down like out of that 80%
institutions any ballpark numbers on
like what's hedge funds versus what
other organizations look like yeah I
think for us we certainly believe hedge
funds or institutions right you're
talking in our opinion about
professional investors who have
underlying people that are trusting them
to
allocate their money according to a
prescribed investment mandate and
they're being paid a fee to do so on and
often case handsomely and I think for a
lot of those types of investors moving
into digital assets has been a leap it's
a leap that a lot of them took probably
starting about two two and a half years
ago but today I think that the
underlying investors are really giving
them really all the wherewithal they
need to invest in in digital currencies
on behalf of clients and we're not just
seeing this in the hedge fund community
you know we're fortunate to count other
types of institutions or other types of
professional investors as clients as
well so that could be an endowment it
could be a registered investment advisor
it could be a private organization it
could be a you know a bank it really
runs the gamut but I would say
overwhelmingly it is going to be when we
talk about institutional flows
overwhelmingly hedge funds and I think
Anthony the reason that that is is
because when you're talking typically
about a hedge fund
there are certainly decision makers at a
hedge fund but there's also going to be
fewer decision-makers than there would
be when you're talking about going
through the investment committee of an
endowment or a pension or something like
that and those organizations also just
tend to move slower so hedge funds tend
to have a conviction in something they
do their due diligence and they kind of
move forward yeah and so obviously to
see that two billion dollars over the
last 12 months give or take kind of
inflow into all of the different funds
that you have one is impressive but it's
even more impressive when I think you
look at it from a good portion of that
call it four to five months ends up
being a global pandemic and economic
shock maybe talk a little bit just about
like how does the macro changes helped
or hurt kind of the argument for
institutions getting exposure and then
other things that you may see as to why
people are seeking out this exposure
yeah I mean I certainly want to be
sensitive and say first of all you know
on behalf of the entire team on you know
everyone globally is is on our mind we
know it is a very challenging time for
individual
for families for companies you name it
and so we certainly want to be
conscientious of you know some of the
uphill battles that a lot of folks are
are fighting amidst the environment but
if you if you drill into what's been
happening in the investment landscape in
the in the wake of that there's been
quite a bit of activity so if you look
back in 2019 before the pandemic head
gracile had a record year we raised over
three hundred million dollars last year
and we've never seen inflows like that
before that momentum really carried
itself into the first quarter of 2020
when we raised over half a billion
dollars in just one quarter and it
really wasn't until the pandemic head in
in late or mid March of 2020 I believe
that we really started to see kind of
what the fallout of that was gonna be
across different asset classes and so
you know definitely being long
volatility was a winning trade in the
first quarter but then what we saw is
that that really subdued in the second
quarter of 2020 and while a lot of risk
assets sold off after the pandemic hit
we saw the resilience of the digital
currency market be a lot more pronounced
than it was for other asset classes
equities bonds etc and so the second
quarter of 2020 broke yet another record
for greyscale we brought in over 900
million dollars in the second quarter of
2020 and you know I think we have to
think about what's driving that and to
some extent you know one might think
that economic uncertainty and not really
knowing what the outlook is going to be
when coated may subside when we may have
a vaccine may just be causing people to
take risk off and be on the sidelines
but I think now what we're seeing is
assets like Bitcoin and just digital
currencies in general are being sought
out by investors looking for
uncorrelated return streams you know new
sources of alpha and again that digital
gold narrative is still really playing
out when things go bad investors are
looking historically to things like
bonds in
but now that subset of investments you
might choose when things go bad include
assets like Bitcoin and I think
especially in the wake of how government
intervention has you know come into the
fold and in the wake of the pandemic
you've just seen this unlimited fiscal
stimulus being injected into the
financial system and when you think
about that it's causing a lot of
investors and a lot of the conversations
we're having with investors to revisit
some of the core attributes of digital
currencies like Bitcoin that do in fact
have a verifiable scarcity to the amount
of Bitcoin that will ever be and when
you start having these conversations
investors really understand why not only
the world has gone increasingly digital
but why a digital currency has now more
than ever a role in the world we're
living in and a role in the world that
we're going to be living and moving
forward yeah it's really interesting to
think about Bitcoin is kind of the
headline right that's what always draws
all the attention that's what everyone
writes about but you guys offer a number
of other assets and so maybe talk a
little bit about what are those other
assets that you offer and then how do
you see the inflows being split up among
those various assets sure so we now have
nine single currency products so we have
products that are just solely and
passively holding Bitcoin Bitcoin cash
aetherium aetherium classic litecoin XRP
stellar horizon and z cash I think I
just hit all nine of them and then the
digital large cap fund is our
diversified offering which holds a
market cap weighted basket of digital
currencies that get to be evaluated
every quarter today that consists of
Bitcoin aetherium litecoin Bitcoin cash
and XRP and so you know when you think
about the different assets that
greyscale products offer investors
exposure to you're really looking at
that upper you know 70% up or 75 up or
80% of the digital currency market today
and I'd say that for a lot of investors
on not you know surprisingly hopefully
for you pom but most investors first
foray into greyscale products is still
usually in Bitcoin and that's not going
to surprise anyone
to this either right Bitcoin is probably
overcome the most adversity it's
probably where investors have spent the
most time and there's the most resources
available to them but I would say it's
interesting to know how much investors
are diversifying away from grace-filled
products so I would say this quarter on
the demand for products in q2 outside of
Bitcoin is up 35% quarter-over-quarter
so we had record quarterly inflows into
the grayscale aetherium trust and we
actually also saw some of the highest
allocations in to you know the grayscale
litecoin trust that we've had all year
so far um as well as into the grayscale
Bitcoin cash trust since I think it was
the second quarter of 2018 so investors
are definitely looking at other products
within within the grayscale family and
that's a theme that's been going on for
a while and one we're monitoring closely
but investors not only see the
diversification benefit of having
digital currency exposure but also
having exposure to more than one digital
currency so I think most people in
crypto will know almost everything that
you just said in terms of the names of
the assets the one that may stick out to
them is horizon talk a little bit about
what that is and why you guys chose to
incorporate that one sure so horizon is
a privacy-preserving digital currency
that was something that came on to our
team's radar over the past couple of
years and I think it dovetails nicely
with grayscale already offering the
grayscale Z cash trust I think from our
perspective and what conversations we
have with investors they believe and
understand that the world in and privacy
with it is changing quite a bit and we
have seen there be quite a bit of demand
for protocols that preserve financial
privacy and we're not talking about
financial private privacy that lends
itself to you nefarious activity or
anything you know that that would be
untoward we're talking about the ability
for investors to be able to store value
or transact in a way that can protect
some of the details of those types of
transactions horizon is an asset however
that kind of builds upon some of those
foundational elements that you may see
in Z cache but also lends itself to
other applications as well that maybe
the code base is e cash or other
privacy-preserving
digital assets don't necessarily lend
themselves to so it's a lesser-known and
probably a certainly a smaller cap
digital asset than some of the other
products we offer but nonetheless
somatically is something that definitely
has and I we believe continues to
resonate with investors and then talk a
little bit about one of the things that
I think investors are scared of but also
some investors are excited about is the
premiums on the various funds so for
those that don't know basically a
premium is when the fund itself holds a
certain amount of assets let's say a
million dollars worth of an asset but
it's actually trading at a value above
that so it could be 1.1 1.2 million
dollars that Delta between where's
trading and the actual asset value is a
premium at times there's certain
vehicles you guys have that have you
know almost no premium right kind of
five ten percent protect premiums all
the way up to I think the ether trust at
one point I saw had like an eight
hundred percent premium and so kind of
just talked a little bit about how you
guys think of the premiums and across
the different assets as well sure yeah
so let's step back for a minute so you
know if someone is an accredited
investor you know they can buy any one
of the grayscale products directly from
us ad net asset value now so far I'm
four out of the ten grayscale products
have been approved for a public
quotation so that's our Bitcoin product
the etherium product aetherium classic
product as well as the grayscale Digital
large cap fund and so it's important for
me to reiterate here that grayscale does
not trade in we're not marking makers
we're not dictating the price at which
any of the four products I just
mentioned are trading in the public
market on any given day instead these
products are really driven by market
demand and market sentiment and so I
think today the price at which these
products trade
in the market is really being driven by
a couple of factors I think one there is
today very very very few if any access
products for digital currency and so as
an investor if you're typically used to
having a brokerage account and I array
whatever it may be and you're used to
accessing stocks bonds ETFs mutual funds
etc through that platform
well now you can also get yourself
digital currency exposure through any
one of the grayscale products that are
that are publicly traded and so there is
kind of an ISA view so liquidity um and
then it also negates the need for
investors to navigate buying
transferring holding storing safekeeping
you know digital currency directly and I
think one of the other big areas where
we see a lot of uses of the grayscale
products is also in retirement accounts
so we do all not only have investors who
want to make these allocations for the
medium to long term but they want to do
so in a tax efficient way and so they
look to deploy investments in
grace-filled products inside IRAs and
Roth IRAs and 401ks and so we're not
only facilitating that in our private
placements which we do for investors
often but also on the public market as
well and so again if you have one of
those types of accounts but you're
restricted to solely buying publicly
listed equities or bonds or ETFs well
then you really would have a very
difficult time buying Bitcoin directly
in that kind of account or buying
aetherium directly in that kind of
account so there again you know having
the gracile product really is providing
a value to investors and giving them the
ability to get exposure whereas
otherwise would not be able to it's
really interesting and I guess as part
of this maybe talk a little bit about
where you see most of the inflows is it
in the public markets or is it in those
private placements yes so the inflows
that we get are only into the private
placements themselves so investors who
are accredited and who are buying the
private placements from us their
liquidity option is selling into the
public market after they've held their
shares for a statutory amount of time in
the case of Bitcoin that's only six
months because that is an SEC reporting
company and the
and some of our other products that are
publicly quoted that's actually a
12-month period so inflows really only
come into the private the private
placement on the secondary market over
time what we've seen and what we believe
will continue to see is that the volume
and the number of shares in the public
market will grow over time as more and
more investors who bought on the primary
side have their shares roll off into the
secondary market and obviously when
people hear inflows they think okay what
about outflows how do you think about
outflows and how do you measure that
it's at all sure so we actually don't
offer redemption programs in our
products so the grayscale products you
know have these ongoing private
placements where we're taking inflows
and then the liquidity option is
actually to move your shares out onto
the public market after that holding
period versus traditional you know
creation redemption process where
actually the share count could in theory
be lowered in the underlying assets sold
that is not in fact the case inside our
products but rather the assets raised
just roll off into the secondary market
and continue to be a part of the
products one of the things that people
have talked a lot about over the years
is a Bitcoin ETF you guys obviously have
the closest thing to that it's a little
bit different structure but it has
served the purpose that an ETF could
serve in terms of allowing people to get
exposure in a liquid way in a various
number of investment mechanisms whether
it's in retirement dollars or not what
are you guys thinking about or kind of
paying attention to in terms of that etf
process and then maybe a potential
approval at some point sure so we think
bitcoin ET yet is a matter of when not a
matter of this I think you know the
regulators have done a fantastic job of
staying ahead of the curve on the
digital currency asset class as a whole
Tom you know you spend a lot of your
time trying to stay on top of what's
going on in the ecosystem I do myself at
times it almost seems untenable because
of how fast the asset class is evolving
and moving day to day week by week
we like to sometimes say you know a week
in the digital currency world is like
six months in the real world
and you know I think with that being
said our regulators have recognized
digital currency Bitcoin in particular
in a lot of ways that lend a lot of
validation to it and should really in
our opinion not be deterrence for
investors accessing the asset class so
you know we've gotten guidance from the
IRS we've gotten guidance from the SEC
we've gotten guidance from the CFTC um
you know the great still Bitcoin trust
is now an SEC reporting company so
they've taken a really proactive
approach and there are in fact ways to
work with regulators on the asset class
within existing frameworks but they're
just not ready to approve an ETF yet and
I think that they've been pretty
explicit about wanting to see certain
dynamics within the market mature a
little bit more things like you know
maybe a more global order book for
Bitcoin may be things like surveillance
sharing agreements um maybe a little bit
more regulation and oversight of the
different marketplaces and venues where
digital assets are being traded and you
know I think that that's something that
certainly we as a firm and me as an
individual I'm excited to kind of see
how the ecosystem continues to mature
I've been in the space now you know
seven years and it's amazing to see how
much progress has been made so I think
again it's gonna be a matter of when not
a matter of if and investors just need
to be patient
um but luckily in the meantime there's
tons and tons of ways for investors to
access digital currency directly through
futures through greyscale products
through all kinds of means um in order
to participate in the asset class now
and not have to wait for an ETF as an
ETF eventually gets approved right when
you say kind of when not if what would
be the potential impact on your business
or kind of what would you guys do
differently when that day comes sure so
you know I do think that it's worth
noting that in 2017 we were working to
move the grayscale Bitcoin trust up to
the New York Stock Exchange as an ETF
and while we made a lot of great
progress with the SEC we ultimately
pulled out of that process recognizing
that they again just
ready for it I mean so I do think that
there will be a time eventually where
you know this product is able to
hopefully one day on you know be able to
achieve that that level of registration
and change that product structure and
eventually we hope to be able to turn
you know the entire product family into
ETFs but we're only you know ten twelve
years into the lifecycle of the the
asset class and again I think we just
need to be patient but you know we'll
certainly be there when our regulators
are ready for it and you know try and
stay on top of those conversations as
much as we can most of the products that
you have rooms all the products you have
or what I would consider kind of
straight down the fairway you want
exposure to X asset either directly or a
basket of them that's what you provide
have you guys thought about or have any
plans to create vehicles where it may be
an asset that then earns interest or any
sort of kind of bells and whistles that
would be attached to not just be direct
exposure to an asset but the kind of
additional value sure so number one I
would just say you know the grayscale
team you know myself included everyone
has really spent their time in financial
services firms banks etc before working
a grayscale and so we're all all too
familiar with every different flavor of
investment product right and so I'd say
at any time our team is maintaining call
it twenty to thirty different product
ideas that we're ready to bring to
market now the question always remains
and the difficulty that we have as a
team is where is it that we are seeing
value and what's feasible for us to do
and what do we think people resonate
with investors versus what are investors
telling us they want in what areas of
the market do they want exposure to so I
may regret this later pomp but if people
ever have ideas for grayscale products
feel free to tweet me at Sun and shine
I'd love to hear your your your ideas
that you have many of you already do
that on a daily if not multiple times a
day basis and we certainly take any and
all of those things under advisement but
what I can share for now is that the
grayscale product family will certainly
not stop at the
ten products there are definitely more
products to come from greyscale you know
that you just open the door for every
and every [ __ ] coin in the world now
thanks again a great scale of vehicle
will tell you though on that point right
there are definitely certain things that
we look for when structuring products
right we're looking for real you know
reference rate in a you know a real
discernible market that's accessible and
regulated we're looking to make sure
that there's sound custodial solutions
around you know products around certain
digital assets that we can in fact go
ahead and create a product around that
digital asset you know the list goes on
and on but I would just say there are
some very practical implications that
definitely need to be considered in the
context of evaluating any digital asset
for inclusion in a grayscale product so
that brings us to one of the most asked
questions that I got which was does that
mean dogecoin is out after the recent
tick tock influence the price increase
you know um I cannot say that we would
ever or would not ever create a
grayscale dogecoin trust but I myself to
have been looking at how Doge has been
reacting in the wake of all that's been
happening with that on tick-tock that is
the politically correct answer I think
it's absolutely incredible to watch
something like that happen well I think
it goes to show you the strength of the
digital currency community right there
are a lot of passionate folks a lot of
passionate voices and you know we're
seeing a ton of financial innovation
coming around it and what a better time
than to be working on it in the wake of
everything going on in the world so as
much as I'm joking about dogecoin it
does bring kind of a more serious
question which is around performance
right so obviously there are a number of
investors that specifically want
exposure to crypto assets because of
past performance or belief in future
performance there are a number of
investors who buy into the qualitative
type argument right hey there's lots of
inflation coming I want to hedge and do
things like that how do you guys think
about the performance of the asset
affecting you to positively
are negatively inflows and kind of
conversations with the institutions that
you speak with sure so I'd say you know
we now have quite a few quarters of
empirical data that are showing us that
investors are tactically adding to their
positions when they see a drawdown in
price again because our products carry
when you buy the private placement a
statutory holding period we're really
serving a community of investors that
are really allocating to digital
currency for the medium to longer term
and so when they see a pullback in price
as a result of any number of factors
that may be affecting it it's been
really rewarding to see that they're
viewing that as an opportunity versus
they were scared we wish we hadn't
gotten in as early we wish we were now
first building our position and so we
work with a lot of institutions to over
time help them average in to a you know
size up to a certain allocation that
they're looking to make and again while
a lot of the focus continues to be in a
lot of the inflows are on assets like
Bitcoin and aetherium it is worth noting
that in the second quarter this year you
know digital assets broadly outperformed
you know most indices and in particular
some of the assets that we provide
products around Z cash aetherium and
stellar were some of the top performers
right Z cash was up 72 percent in q2
aetherium up 62 percent and I think
stellar on a similar footing and so I
think a lot of investors are paying
attention to price movements and then
also looking at portfolio construction
what does your portfolio look like when
you make room for 50 basis points and
digital currency or you know a hundred
and fifty basis points in digital
currency and they back test it and they
do see that this can really help build a
more resilient portfolio and that's
unjust undisputably something that is
definitely resonating with investors so
there's a lot of investors who will say
I hear all of the kind of increase in
price in a quarter half a year a year
whatever but for example in March there
was a 50% drawdown in a single day of
Bitcoin
maybe talk a little bit about kind of
one any stories from watching that
happen but then also to you guys have a
very unique kind of structure in that
either one the investors are in an
illiquid vehicle meaning that even
though the asset is liquid they can't
sell their stake in the private fund or
to is most of that drawdown or kind of
the most severe part of that drawdown
happened after the stock market it
closed right and even if you held the
liquid shares you were kind of hands
tied till the morning there so maybe
just kind of talk through like want any
cool stories from that day and then to
how the structure either helps or hurts
investors in those types of situations
sure well I will say that seven years of
working in the digital currency
ecosystem I have an iron stomach I have
been through so many days of not just
50% draw downs but even more than that
and at times when you couldn't even
point to any reason why digital currency
might be moving or having a precipitous
drop so I myself feel unfazed by by
those events right I certainly am
somebody who is allocated to digital
currency personally and for you know the
long-term believe that you know we're
still in the early innings of you know
where this asset class can ultimately go
when I think back to the the big
drawdown that we saw in March I can tell
you with certainty there was not a
single email or phone call from an
investor that day to myself or anyone on
our team saying oh my god I need to get
out of this I can't believe this asset
class can do this on in such a short
period of time
did we instead have conversations with
investors around what may be driving
some of that I'm seeing how other risk
assets are really pretty much almost any
asset or investable area of the world
kind of couldn't dodge their way out of
this this global liquidity crisis and
massive deleveraging yeah we were
certainly having that conversation but
there was never a run for the hills
because digital currency is taking a big
dip again instead these are moments
where investors do you
things opportunistically and you know
look to those kinds of moments to again
really add to a position yeah it's it's
very very interesting one of the things
that people have been talking about a
lot online and a joke and say it's back
of the napkin math only with people who
may not be the best at math is there's a
rumor that greyscale is buying up all
the Bitcoin right and what really people
are talking about is they're trying to
back in to how much bitcoin is grayscale
accumulating how much bitcoin is being
mined in a day a week a month the court
or whatever and so this thought process
of like oh my god grayscales gonna own
all the bitcoin either out of fear or
out of like oh if greyscale owns all the
bitcoin then of course the price has to
go up because there's none for everybody
else right so maybe just kind of talk
through like I'm sure you've seen that
or flying around on Twitter like
thoughts and kind of any response there
yeah you know it's an interesting
calculation that back of the napkin
calculation that some folks are doing
right you know the the the process that
people or the calculation that people
are undertaking is that particularly in
the wake of the bitcoin having which we
experienced earlier this year what they
are saying is that the rate in which
bitcoin are going into the grayscale
bitcoin trust is going in to the
investment vehicle that we manage at a
rate faster then new bitcoin are coming
online and becoming part of the
circulating supply of bitcoin now what
should you take away from that you
should not be taking away that grayscale
is buying up all the Bitcoin and there's
gonna be none left for you well you
should be taking away from that is what
that should tell you about investment
demand greyscale is an asset manager and
we are trying to satisfy investors
appetite for exposure to digital
currencies and in this case exposure to
Bitcoin and so if the rate at which we
are having to try to satisfy our
investor demand is happening faster than
new Bitcoin is coming online then that
should be an important indication to
anybody undertaking this that demand is
outstripping the new supply coming into
the market
so our inflows and our stair creation
has nothing to do with how many Bitcoin
are coming online are coming into
circulation but should instead again be
viewed as really a measure of demand
which is why on a quarterly basis you
know we put out this asset raising
report you know this is why each quarter
we trying detail out for investors which
are the products that you know achieve
the most inflows which are the investor
types that were most active in the prior
quarter are there any trends or are
there any interesting data points to
extrapolate for investors because
ultimately we're trying to give
investors intelligent and actionable
insights and if this report being the
largest asset manager and the space can
do that then it's really quickly quite
become really the de facto sentiment
indicator for investment demand for the
asset class so I think a lot of people
then say okay where does greyscale get
the Bitcoin or other assets that that
they do when they're creating shares
actually fulfill that demand sure so
some of you may know and pop you may
have spoken to him before our sister
firm is called Genesis their CEO is my
friend and colleague Mike Morrill and so
Genesis and greyscale work very closely
together
Genesis is an over-the-counter digital
currency trading business that also has
a very robust lending and borrowing
facility as well as now a derivatives
business and because Genesis is a broker
dealer we work exclusively with Genesis
on sourcing digital currencies that go
into all of the grayscale products right
for a grayscale it's really important
for us and to the investors we serve
that we're doing everything as compliant
as possible and so working with a
regulated entity you know a broker
dealer in this case really allows us to
do so and so Genesis is counterparties
are all either individuals funds holders
minors companies anybody who is dealing
in digital assets but
can pass all of the anti money
laundering know your customer all the
background checks etcetera that any a
counterparty would need to be approved
in order to trade with a broker dealer
and so we work exclusively with them and
you know their counterparties are now
providing a pretty robust pool of
liquidity so that as investors are
coming into the funds we have ample
ability to buy Bitcoin or the applicable
digital asset in order to fulfill
whatever demand is being had I didn't
and I guess as some as you go into other
assets so not just Bitcoin or ether and
have the large market caps does that get
harder does that get easier like how do
you think about actually acquiring it
and so go to the extreme example if you
started a dogecoin vehicle right and
it's got a smaller market cap and you
need to go acquire a bunch like what
does that do to change these of
processor operational yeah so I think
that actually dovetails nicely with a
comment I made before which is like
there are some you know operational
hurdles that we need to make sure are
achievable when we think about product
creation so if there is not going to be
in a liquid enough or accessible enough
or a compliant market for Genesis to be
able to go out and source digital assets
in in order to satisfy the demand that
investors may have for a given product
we offer and inherently the underlying
asset that that products invested in
then that poses a big challenge for us
and would be a roadblock to us being
able to serve certain types of digital
currencies inside our products it's also
worth noting though that in some
instances we also have investors who or
the own digital currency and can
facilitate creations of grayscale
products using digital currency they
already own so it negates the need for
Genesis to go out and source it but
rather those investors are coming to us
with digital currency they already have
can instead invest it on into the
products so they then end up owning
shares rather than the digital
currencies themselves and again when
those come through because they're
running through a broker
dealer relying on partners like chain
alysus and elliptic and all of the great
blockchain surveillance and monitoring
tools that are available to us to order
in order to make sure that the coins
were taking into our products are in
fact clean
I normally end each episode asking the
same two questions we've already had the
pleasure of talking about your favorite
book and an alien so I have two separate
ones that are more grayscale specific
kind of and looking in the future the
first is as you kind of evaluate the
company today and as you move forward
what do you feel like is the company's
greatest weakness or the thing that you
want to spend the most time working on
to improve over the next call at 12 to
24 months you know you didn't prepare me
for this all right I'd say for us on an
area that we're really investing heavily
in over call it the next year your plus
is going to be a lot more technology we
are really wanting to make investors
experiences with us evermore tailored to
the types of products that they're
interested in and want to you know make
sure that people have you know an even
better experience with greyscale and I
think along with that is also continuing
to really invest in talent you know
we've been continuing to hire and expand
the greyscale team and I think that we
will also really continue invest in
people but I wouldn't say people are a
weakness at the moment just to be clear
I love that answer didn't mean to put
you on the spot and then I guess the
second question is you're already the
largest digital currency asset manager
in the world got four billion dollars in
assets got a number of different
vehicles and which people can invest
what is the goal or the mission at this
point but where does greyscale go and if
you kind of look out you know ten years
plus from now how big can this get or
kind of what do you and the rest of the
team aspire to build here yeah I would
say that for us it's really about
opening up exposure to the digital
currency asset class I think we all
continue to believe that it is early
days that digital currencies as a you
know looking at their market
is really almost nothing compared to the
size of some of the markets they stand
to disrupt and so if we're successful in
our mission we are not only continuing
to offer you know best-in-class
institutional grade solutions for
investors to gain exposure to this Mason
asset class but we're also going to be a
meaningful piece of helping to educate
individuals and entities and
institutions about the asset class and
also being you know good stewards of
seeing the technology continued to grow
in advance and so I think from our
standpoint we're constantly looking for
opportunities to serve in those
capacities and really grow the pie as a
whole really for people everywhere so
awesome where can people find you online
and if they want to learn more about
greyscale or investing in any of the
products where can they go sure so you
can find me I'm I'm on Twitter and I'm a
little scared after this this chat with
you Tom but you can find me at Sun and
shine at my last name on Twitter you can
find greyscale on at greyscale Co that's
greyscale dot Co and there we have a
whole host of great research reports all
kinds of primers on digital currencies
if you're looking to get a little
smarter on a specific digital currency
that you haven't maybe spent as much
time on before and then certainly our
team you know likes to and will often
post as much as we can
various content we're putting out
webinars we're doing really any way to
engage with our team certainly on
Twitter so our Twitter handle for grey
scale is at greyscale invest and we look
forward to connecting with all of you
they're awesome and Michael it's always
a pleasure to talk to you you guys are
absolutely killing it so congrats on all
these success and keep cheering for you
but I will do it again in the future
awesome thanks pop this is great